كشفت صحيفه الاسرائيليه في تحقيق المشترك
لها مع لايت هاوس ريبورت هذه المؤسسه غير
الحكوميه التي تجري تحقيقات استقصائيه
تحقيقهم المشترك كشف عن رحله غير عاديه
قامت بها طائره تعود لواحد من ابرز منتجي
برامج التجسس الاسرائيليه الى الخرطوم هذا
ملف وموضوع وقفه مع الحدث مع خالد
الغرابلي اهلا بك يا خالد
عندما تظهر في مكان غالبا تظهر ومعها
المشاكل تظهر مع المشاكل وهي ظهرت بحسبها
ارسل التي اجرت التحقيق مع مؤسسه لايت
هاوس وهي مجموعه من من هي مؤسسه تعمل مع
العديد من الشركاء الاعلاميين في
التحقيقات والاستقصائيه قالت ان هذا
الطائره رصدت بحسب مناره على هذا الشكل
هذا ال- ال- المؤسسه التي تابعت تحرك
الطائره روسيا روسدت في الثامن عشر
من مايو الماضي همم تخرج من قبرص باتجاه
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وبقيت على ارض
المطار لنحو 45 دقيقه ثم غادرت لماذا هذه
الطائره عندما تظهر تظهر ومعها المشاكل
لان هذه الطائره تعود لشخص يدعى دليانه
سنرى سوره التالديان همم بعد قليل تلد
اليان عندما يذكر اسمه نتذكر هذا هو الذي
نتحدث عنه همم
عندما نقول ديليا
ليان كان مسؤول وحده وحده الاستخبارات همم
المعلوماتيه تحديدا التي تقوم بالتجسس في
الجيش الاسرائيلي هم وحده النخبه التي
تستخدم التكنولوجيا التجسس
من خلال المعلوماتيه واللي تمنح الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما يريد من معلومات الرجل
عندما انتهى من عمله في هذه الوحده يبدو
انها شعر باهميه من يحصل على مثل هذه
المعلومات وقراره فتح شركه تعمل في هذا
المجال انشا شركه اشترى شركه قام بعمليات
دمج ووصل في النهايه الى حجم معرفه يسمح
له بان يقدم خدماته في معارض دوليه الى
وكالات الاستخبارات بشكل عام في العالم
ليقول لهم انا قادر على تقديم خدمات همم
لكم همم هذا الرجل عندما يعرض هذه الخدمات
سئل احد الخبراء الاسرائيليه ما الفرق
بينه بين الخدمات التي يعرضها وبين الشركه
التي صنعت بيجاسوس
والفضيحه الكبيره التي كانت تستخدم فيها
هذا البرنامج التجسس على النشاطات وعاملين
في مجال الاعلام الرد كان انا بيجاسوس او
الشركه التي صنعت بيجاسوس عندما تعمل تعمل
وفق القانون الاسرائيلي واحيانا تمثل حتى
الدوله الاسرائيليه يعني حتى وان انتقدت
وفرضت عليها عقوبات هذه الشركه لانها باعت
ااا انظمتها الى جهات استخدمت في انتهاك
اجراءات انتهك حقوق الانسان لكن يبقى على
الاقل من ناحيه نظريه هناك اطار معين حدود
معينه
لسلوكها وجهها يمكن ان تحاسب في النهايه
لكن في ما يخص فعل ليان وشركات التليكسا
همم هو في النهايه شركه خاصه
القانون هو المصلحه وبالتالي تستطيعين ان
تتخيلي لمن يمكن ان يبيع هذه الانظمه التي
تستخدم للتجسس على الناس
الاخلاقيات كما قلت هي فقط مصلحته وحتى
الان هو لا يعاقب وبالتالي لا نعلم لمن
باع بالضبط ولا نعلم هذه الانظمه هذه
البرامج تستخدم للتجسس على من بالضبط ربما
بتكون هناك مراحل لاحقا من هذه الفضيحه
يمكن ان نقول ان طائرات هذا رجل او هذا
الطائره شوهدت في دبي ابو ظبي الرياض شمال
افريقيا في العديد من الدول الافريقيه
وبالتالي الرجل له يبدو نشاط في العديد من
المجالات ولا يعرف حدود مجالاتهم بالضبط
طيب خلي حسب هذا التحقيق ما الذي حملت هذه
الطائره الى الخرطوم
كما قلت عندما
لم تاتي وهي تحمل الزهور للشعب السوداني
او لحل مشاكله هذه الطائره عندما جاءت
وبحسب التحقيق الذي نشر جاءت وهي تحمل همم
منظومه التجسس صنعت في الاتحاد الاوروبي
تسمح بتحويل الهاتف الذكي الهاتف المحمول
الى جاسوس شخصيه لك يعني كل ما تقولين
يسجله عليك كل ما تفعلينه يصوره لك يدخل
في جهازك يستطيع ان يعرف كل ما اعرفك كل
ال- ال- الاتصالات التي قمت بها مع معرفه
واصدقائك على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
وحتى على الرسائل الخاصه يعرف تفاصيل
حياتك واعرف اين انت يحدد مكانك
جغرافي وبالتالي عندما تقدم هذه المعلومات
لجهه تريد القاء القبض على الناشطين
تستطيع ان تعرف كل ما يفعله هذا الشخص
بالادله
وتستطيع ايضا ان تحدد مكانه لالقاء القبض
عليه لمن وجود وصل هذه
التجسس هذه وصلت بحسب التحقيق الى قوات
التدخل السريع جماعه حميدتي
ويبدو انها وصلت بشكل سري لانهم قالوا حسب
مصادرهم ان بمجرد ان يعرفوا ان عرف حصوم
حميدتي بوصول هذه الشحنه همم صرعت اخوات
التدخل السريع بنقل هذه همم المنظومه الى
دار بعيد تماما عن همم اي همم امكانيه لان
يصل اليها الجيش هذه معلومات في غايه
الاهميه لماذا نفهم من هذه المعلومات اولا
هم يقولون محللين استضافات صدفه صحيح او
صادفتها الصحيفه ماذا قالوا قالوا حميدتي
رجل مسؤول عن
ملف الذهب في السودان رجل تحت امرته جيش
خاص به رجل
الروسيه رجل زار اسرائيل مرتين منذ يونيو
2021 دائما بحسب هذه الصحيفه هذا الرجل
يمكن ان يستخدم
هذه المنظومه للتجسس على الناشطين
والمعارضين السودانيين وبالتالي مواجهه
شباب الثوره الذين يخرجون في التظاهرات
هذا جزء من ما يمكن ان افهمهم قالوه في
تحليلاتهم لكن هناك جزء اخر هم قالوا ايضا
ان هذا بحسب محللين هذا يمكن ان يستخدم
كجزء من صراع على السلطه هدف غايه الخطوره
على حديث لانه الظاهر في الامور ان حميدتي
والبرهان السودان معا لكن عندما تاتي شحنه
تستخدم للتجسس على الهواتف الذكيه وتنقل
بشكل سريع لطرف واحد من طرفين الحكم في
السودان هذا معناه انه يمكن ان تستخدم على
المتظاهرين
وايضا على الجهه الاخرى على جماعه البرهان
والجيش وهذا معناه همم هناك صراع على
السلطه بين حماتي بين البرهان وهذا لا
يطمئن على الاطلاق
خالد همم شكرا جزيلا